[Music]
foreign
I never knew he was again
[Music]
run away
[Applause]
[Music]
on your cruel game
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I hope you enjoyed this video uh big
thanks to flowtoys for sponsoring it and
giving me a reason to go out and play
and flow in town if you'd like to grab a
set of these pod POI LED uh POI with the
FPC tethers you can do that by heading
on over to flowtoys.com and using my
special promo code drexfactor 2023 that
will get you a discount on your order
and it helps out the channel so
everybody wins go check that out thanks
once again to flowtoys for sponsoring
this video yay and speaking of thank
yous I also have to thank the friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel that
is Lane machinski and pakka pakunan
thank you both so very much for
supporting my work my channel and my
mission also this video would not be
possible were it not for the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon they and the people
listed down in the description helped to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all for your very very generous support
and if you out there watching are not
currently a supporter but you like to
become one you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you if you'd like to check out
some other flow videos that I've done I
will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of them down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video right here based upon
your past viewing habits so maybe give
that a look as well thank you so much
for watching make sure to get outside to
flow yourself today and I will see you
with a new video on Friday
peace